welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host Tisha mizzouz and on this week's
episode I was joined by Karen from a
company called Thor companies Karen has
been on a fantastic Journey we're
talking over a decade or recruitment
experience and over the the last nine
years he was the sixth employee of the
business that he's been part of for
nearly a decade and he's now actively
involved in the business that has Circa
130 people in the business today
globally they have offices in London New
York Stockholm LA and his role has
really evolved and he's become someone
that is known to be a troubleshooter is
known to be someone that can get the
best out of people and teams so in this
episode we're going to really dive into
loads of leadership philosophies how
they've really Diversified and grown the
business and so much more enjoy the
episode
Karen welcome to the podcast thank you
for having me looking forward to talking
about your recruitment career you've
been in the industry for over a decade
13 years we're not counting 13 years so
planning to unpack uh I think what I
always like to do before I ask you the
the million pound question that we
always start with
but just like to unpack it for the
listeners in terms of sort of parts of
your journey and where you're at today
so feel free to correct me if I get any
of this wrong but just just for everyone
listening so as you said being in the
industry for 13 years
started your recruitment career with an
S3 brand Progressive worked there for
three and a half years
and then you joined the business that
you are still part of NOW Thor companies
yep uh been a big part of that Journey
the sixth employee
and now this business has scaled to suck
100 people
have different offices globally and
you've always operated in different
parts of of the world
and your your role which is why I'm
really excited to sort of unpack a few
of these things from at the moment I'm
sure there's loads of different things
you get involved with but the way that
you described it to me was a sort of
free key areas that you find yourself in
which is managing the sales of the life
science business
run a team of ta and actually enrolled
in there and then you're also involved
in l d so that's why I was really Keen
to unpack your journey because I think
you you've been involved in all
different parts of a growing recruitment
business but we're always like to start
and I'm sure this is something new for a
lot about particularly at Thor is I'd
love to hear your take on
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you believe make up a highly
successful recruitment concern in in
today's market I'd love to hear your
perspective on that I like when you say
today's market because like you said 13
years in the industry I think my
perception uh and I'm sure other people
in my position would say yeah hard work
commitment uh you know all those things
great communication skills they're
standard they need to be there the
resilience piece I think in today's
market when you add to that list for me
it would be commercial awareness I think
people when they're switched on they're
curious commercially to know what's
happening in the market I think that's a
good sign of a successful recruitment in
the making recruiter in the making
accountability is big
uh given how recruitment is done today
the emphasis on yields dph
um what is the business doing from a
profitability perspective I think if
people feel accountable they perform
better I.E they know what their goals
and targets are so they're accountable
towards them so I think I think those
would be the addition to the resilience
the hard work piece that everyone talks
about apart from that I would say yeah
drive people are really driven people
are self-aware and I think I definitely
heard this on one of your podcasts and I
thought about it that's actually yeah
pretty much what we look for as well
people who are moldable people who are
willing to try different things all of
those traits in my opinion I think yeah
that you're you're set for a good
recruitment career if you've got that in
locker yeah so many great things there I
guess I really want to focus on this
journey that you've been on with with
thought I think a lot of people are
really interested in that but I have to
sort of ask and always like to sort of
start here
how how would you describe current
before recruitment I think if I'm honest
growing up I didn't have many Role
Models I don't come from a massive like
a privileged family but we had enough
food money and all that jazz but it's
all right I never had like the need to
look up to someone I was content before
recruitment the reality is I've got
degree in engineering I've got Masters
in finance when I was able to sort of
add two and two together I was like okay
I need a I need to make money that's I'm
driven by money clearly waste the most
amount of money Finance seemed to be
everyone sort of wanted to be an
investment bank or something okay we'll
go into Masters in finance we'll turn
into a yeah high profile Investment Bank
or something like that obviously didn't
happen because I graduated at a peak of
the financial crisis other than you must
have been quite young back then 2008
2009 I had no choice fell into
recruitment but I think to answer your
question Hisham I feel
always even at a young age 14 15 I was
doing stuff I was you know going to my
dad's Mill uh picking up all the scrap
metal selling that to the scrap dealers
making a few quid there when other
university
yes I had the old job at Sainsbury's and
and all that stuff that people do but I
think I was more buzzing about
um getting a suitcase of costume jewelry
from China or India and going to
Greenwich Market or Covent Garden Market
going to the markets and selling that
you know that that was me so I just
loved being the Villa dealer but that's
also where I learned I'm good
talking to people I don't have a fear of
approaching people so I think all of
that made me feel when I did decide that
okay this could be a industry I can I
can actually try it out those were the
reasons that I can make a lot of money
I'm good with people so yeah that was me
before recruiting I love that
um so what and I always like asking this
question because a lot of people do fall
into the industry as you know like let
me just touching on this earlier but
like what what do you think this amazing
Korean industry has maybe given you as a
person professionally personally that
maybe you least expected when you was at
that part of your life and you sort of
fell into it sure
that's very hard for me to answer but I
think the reality is that there's a lot
I've learned in the last 10 15 years
about
I've learned about myself I mean my
ability this resilience piece that you
just asked me the characteristics of a
good recruiter I didn't know I had it in
me to the extent I do now
obviously with time your threshold to
deal with rejections and failures you
you learn and you pick up and you move
on but I think yeah for me what I've got
from this career is obviously the
financial upside which we don't make you
know it's a given if you're good you
make a lot of money so that's their good
good lifestyle
um great house good sort of yeah
holidays and all that stuff but I think
for me is the especially I thought the
opportunity to work with the people I
work with to learn from them and being
able to see different aspects of how to
run a business so you can you can say
that that's outside of recruitment but
it still has been part of my recruitment
Journey dealing with people how to
manage how to get the most out of your
people
um how to approach a difficult
conversation with ease so just just all
of that puts like perspective I've got
perspective of my time in the industry
nice love that because I don't know I'm
a
huge advocate of people choosing a
career in recruitment just because I
think just some of the things you're
saying now there's so many amazing
things that come with a successful
criminal recruitment that you learn
about yourself professionally personally
but I guess what I was Keen to ask you
and then we'll sort of move on to to
your journey in the last sort of nine
years what what are some of the things
as a recruiter do you think you learn
within that S3 environment earlier on
that maybe you still live by today out
of Interest so you're asking me what did
I take from S3 or what still sticks with
me yeah like is there anything that just
before we move on to yeah I'm just
curious to see about those sort of first
three and a half years Esther are very
renowned for their training and very
high competitive environment just always
curious is there anything that I don't
know you that you learn in that
environment that yeah you still live by
today you still find yourself talking to
people about in in Thor companies today
um man like I said training there was
really good still like I look back at
the days those training formats in the
West End they were great but I think for
me personally that was it I learned
recruitment there the basics of
recruitment I've always been someone
that I just look around me or you're
doing okay that's working for you I'm
going to try that I'm going to put a
spin on that oh you're doing that I'm
going to copy that I'm going to apply so
not really
sort of uh you know
that they've taught me this I think yeah
a few things lead sheets I think lead
sheets
my manager was like where's your lead
sheet and I don't think that was pretty
good I'm very good at Market mapping
still I'm heavily involved in sort of
identifying new markets new sort of uh
geographies and so that where where
there's money will follow so yeah the
lead sheet piece was from S3 a day plan
something small having structure you're
doing client work in the morning you're
doing candidate work in the afternoon
um that accountability also in terms of
your targets uh you need to be doing x
amount of dialouts or interviews to do
deals those ratios so seeing a
recruitment business from a ratio
perspective I think I learned that at S3
and I say I learned that at S3 it was
predominantly my manager Nick who's
still my boss we've been working
together for yeah 13 years Nick was very
much like okay you've got an interview
ratio of four to one you need to bring
that down to three so you need to work
on your candidate quality that ability
to oversee the entire recruitment
process be analytical about it uh that
was good mbrs
you know monthly business reviews I
think people view them as okay this is a
tasting session I'm going to get told
off by my manager I'm just like this is
a great opportunity as a consultant to
spend some time with your manager go
through your month in numbers what's
working what's not working what's the
target so there's there's loads of good
stuff we've uh and I'm not saying it's
just exclusive to S3 in the industry the
the reason why I ask is because I'm sure
you see this now in in um thought but
like in the modern world there's always
something new gold and shiny that are I
can try it this way on these things and
you typically hear recruiters that have
been in the industry for a long time the
importance of getting back to basics so
I was yeah I'm just curious to hear what
you sort of picked up that maybe you
still live by I I wanted to ask you
because you just mentioned him there
Nick that that's a really long time
working for someone who yeah I still
know your boss what what do you think
are some of the things that
how do you think he's inspired you how
do you think he's
LED in a way that has made you be
someone that has been committed to
helping him on his journey he's helped
you on your journey I don't know what
are some of the things that you think
Nick's done really well that has
obviously really resonated you and kept
you engaged and motivated for this
entire team time to be on on the journey
with him sure so I think to give you
some context me and Nick didn't like
each other at this time I'm brilliant no
I think we did a business trip in Oslo
and we got off at Heathrow on the way
back we didn't even say bye we just went
anyway that's a long time ago
um what happened after that trip I think
he realized that I'm good and I also
realized bloody hell he is really good
so we both saw that this potential and I
can learn a lot I've always been open to
the idea if I can learn something from
you I'll work around you I'll compromise
and I'll come in line with whatever you
want me to do so that kind of
relationship started there and then
since then I would say he's always had
my back in particular so when the
director's S3 would be giving him a hard
time about me he will fight my corner
and yet we all have ups and downs I
think they were
to remember like one or two more bad
months for me where the deals weren't
coming
uh my problem was I never had a vertical
I never stuck to a vertical so if I was
to give some advice to myself it
probably would be stick to a vertical it
works that's another one thing we picked
up S3 I would say you know having a
vertical patch and actually mapping it
out it's pretty good so to answer that
previous question so NYX yeah he's been
he's been a maid he's been my mentor
throughout my career I think I think his
leadership is more about it has the
vision guys this is what means for me
this is what it could mean for you but
because we work together so uh for so
many years he actually knows what's
important for me it's my family it's the
financial perks it's a recognition so
whatever he
um whatever project he gives me or he's
running we will have that understanding
I know he wants Perfection he probably
wants everything to be done in the best
way quickest by pleasing all the
shareholders I know that so I'll just
start thinking and acting like that so
yeah he's he's been very uh instrumental
over the last couple years particular
especially in the pandemic so he had a
plan he communicates his plan his plan
really well and we can see that it will
work we just need to give it our best so
I don't know if that answers your
question but that is just like that
trust has been there from a long time
and now it's the case of okay we would
disagree on something we'll end up
agreeing eventually compromise here and
there and and that just works no I think
there's some great learnings in there
for any aspiring leaders or current
leaders he's obviously that really
understands what your drivers are I
think the best leaders understand what
those are or at least work really hard
to know what what um drivers different
people have and yeah I think it sounds
easy to be able to clearly articulate
your vision and what you want to things
but that's actually really difficult
especially when you're trying to get
other people on that Journey right so I
think that's a really good skill so I
guess
help me out here then and help us out
the people listening like in terms of
four as a business early on obviously
been there for for nine years
um obviously what you shared them in you
can feel free to add in your context but
obviously early years I think you shared
with the FED says a bit treated a bit
more like a lifestyle business and you
did a lot in the oil and gas yeah so
predominantly an oil recruitment company
or recruitment companies yeah and then
obviously one of the the big I'm sure
there's been quite a few milestones and
the pivotal moments but one of the
pivotal moments that then actually ended
up being a catalyst with the growth of
the business was 2016. correct all
crisis so just described to us like
going into that the business was did you
say it was like what seven or eight like
four to seven I think we were nine
people
um we were doing really well even as a
lifestyle business I think Nick Chrisley
like all the guys were pulling together
having a lot of fun making a lot of
money and we were like guys we're ready
all right come on let's let's take some
risk we were in a office in Clapham
Chris was always like no no need to be
in the city he loves the city anyway but
we committed to a big fat lease uh moved
in I think we moved in the month of yeah
probably October November time
um and then six months later
Boom the oil price drops from 120 I
think it's hovering around 30 40.
and I was like no no everything's going
to be all right guys everything was all
going to be all right but the reality
was it was it still isn't all right in
that industry all we knew was oil all
our contacts all our dealings were
heavily exposed to that one industry
lesson learned diversification is good
uh yeah that was the Catalyst we were
like okay guys we are obviously very
good either we can pack up you know go
back to S3 because we were pretty we
were good billers very employable in my
opinion we could rather do that or come
on there's a challenge here what are we
prepare to do let's go one more time and
that paid off we Diversified into other
geographies uh we were very good
Headhunters because we never had
databases I think that's one thing very
unique about us we are really good
Headhunters we're very good Market
mappers we know exactly who to call for
what job hey we don't work generous jobs
they're very specialist job so we work
in markets where to do a placement
there's only let's say a circle 300
people in a country that do that job so
you know pretty much everyone like we've
got something can we replicate that in
Sweden in Denmark which worked can we
try other Industries we only did oil can
we do Tech Chris had a huge background
in Tech anyway it was S3 recruiting in
the sap Market in the UK
so from that we ventured out from nine
people we went back to six
we had to let go of a few people
uh and then yeah 2017 I would say the
life science business really kicked off
and everything just kind of followed uh
it was 15 16 people all together 2017
and then yeah like you said we're 132
today across three key markets across
four yeah office locations so yeah so
just to just to make sure everyone
understood that so the three key markets
now are Tech life science and
engineering okay so just quickly on just
I want to take you back to that moment
when the the barrel of oil sorry to
obviously it's quite painful it's all
right you learn from it but like this is
what people want to I guess hear and
learn from like how did that actually
feel when happened you said like oh it's
going to be all right guys what what was
actually going through your mind when
you realized actually guys I don't think
this is actually going to go back like
how would you believe it I was actually
on the phone to a big engineering
manager in a massive International oil
and gas company we're very good at
building reports we had relationship
with this guy we met him a couple of
times I was actually trying to convince
him he's going to be all right he's
telling me this is done this is over I'm
like no no Stein they'll be all right
trust me get this another contractor in
no so I think reality is credible credit
to you uh Nick again came through we
took some salary Cuts around that time
we took a long holiday summer for us is
normally very quiet Nick with my guys
there's no business why don't we just
take a long holiday unpaid uh but come
on this is your contribution towards you
know your commitment and we're working
on a plan the plan was to go Life
Sciences so yeah I think I think I was
scared I'm not going to lie to you that
was I was just having my first kid
around that time I was expecting a baby
yeah it was August time and I was really
scared this is in July and guys what's
happening like what is happening and to
be fair I actually didn't know this
about me that um I can actually recruit
another Market I thought I'm an oil and
gas recruiter stabang is my bread and
butter Trondheim Bergen our locations
I'm good at but Norway that's all I know
but the reality is I think when you're
in those situations you learn to adapt
and and thank God I went through that I
feel like Nick and Chris particularly at
that time they were really good
catalysts for guys adapt adapt new
skills adapt new markets go try it out
we don't have two months to try new
markets you're good enough to make a
call in two weeks so we were trying
markets new markets ourselves I did Life
Sciences uh I did Tech I did everything
I did Nigeria I did America I did
Belgium all sorts but again that that
trust uh that that sort of encouragement
from your you know owners in a way goes
a long way and it does push you out of
your comfort zone and you achieve great
things hey everyone a real quick one
from me this podcast would not be
possible without our amazing podcast
Partners Vin cherry and Source breaker
because you listen to this podcast you
were able to get your hands on exclusive
savings on both of these award-winning
products if you're a growing recruitment
business you have to check out Vin
Cherry who are an all-in-one operating
system system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
Source breaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products so
curious I think this is the sort of
right moment to ask with the couple of
things that you mentioned there like you
said obviously now you're in free core
markets said you've always been
excellent at Market mapping like I think
people will be really curious to sort of
hear your perspective and take on like
now there's probably a bit more of a
science to it like back then you said
let's just adapt let's try different
things but what would you say are some
of the like if if you were to start a
brand new patch tomorrow
um and you were looking for a market
that you think could be sustainable uh
could there could have be sort of plenty
of growth in the market there's plenty
of money to be made it's within niche as
you said within the vertical what are
some of the sort of yeah key indicators
or things that kind of looks for when
we're looking at a market to go you know
what I think this is well worth putting
resource and time into what are some of
the key indicators that you now look for
in terms of a market that you think is
well worth going into focusing on and
potentially building a business around I
think I think to just base it on a uh
online search or a digital search might
be not the right one but I would
personally for me or when I've done it
I've seen what I can leverage that we
have today for example engineering was a
very good add-on to what we knew on the
oil side because there were some
overlaps in terms of the skill set a
health and safety engineer in oil and
gas could also do a health and safety
stuff on a uh yeah on a project for
engineering industry so I would say for
leverages what what you've got already
what are the add-ons to that market but
if I'm honest with you and again I I did
pick this up from S3 I don't know if I'm
giving too much away here
um knowing what your competition does
I got that from a very very small
interaction with Russell Clement who was
the CEO back then and it was just a
informal conversation and his feedback
to us was as managers like you should
always know what your competition is
doing because we should follow them and
then beat them
again that's quite an old school
um from the past but the reality is I'm
looking at how many people let's say we
pick up a skill set based on these
conversations what the competition is
doing your own commercial awareness
kicks in for example now with the energy
bills what they're doing it's it's a
no-brainer that we need to there's going
to be a huge investment towards
unconventional sources okay so we'll be
saying there is a huge demand okay great
so you follow you follow your nose there
then then for me from a recruiting
perspective I'm looking at how many jobs
are being advertised in there what's the
average salaries there um how many
people are let's say in a city doing
that job as per LinkedIn okay so those
are the kind of things I'll be looking
at and that will allow me to yeah
conclude my due diligence and say okay
that's the market I want to go into or I
don't want to go into that because the
average fees are low volume's not there
whatever yeah no some gretins out there
so curious to ask you then I've had a
number of people that I've sat down with
who have said how competitive and
challenged in the UK Market is uh even
if they're in a nation and these types
of things even had someone recently say
like they would yeah never do the UK
Market again and only do men and Europe
in these things just curious to get your
thoughts on like what what do you think
of some of the the key principles to
recruiting successfully in places like
Norway Scandinavia
internationally because I think a lot of
people if I'm honestly I'm speaking to
obviously have their business in the UK
but actually are just doing a bit like
you guys that only recruit in places
outside of the UK I don't know if you
have anything to share there on maybe
things you've had to learn the hard way
but what what are some of the the sort
of principles you think to to being
successful in
um yeah International International
markets you think I think you're going
to have a long-term Vision so you can't
go into these markets definitely not in
Mainland you're definitely not with
Scandinavia I think I can you know name
10 15 businesses top my head that failed
because uh I think they go in with the
UK mindset of looking at it as a
transactional piece of business I think
that's the first mistake because these
guys they don't know you uh don't really
trust you anyway but then if you're
going in with that attitude
you are bound to
you know not build a relationship you're
not going to build a relationship you
might do the odd placement here and
there
um but you won't build relationships so
I think that's key you've got to be
patient you've got to have a long-term
play what does that country or that
market means to your overall strategy
what does it mean from a headcom
perspective or because of all of those
criterias are big ones you can't be
playing at it you've got to commit to it
and you've got to be able to see through
the you know one two three four months
where you don't make any money but
you're learning learning learning and
then when it actually starts to come in
then how do we expand and grow and
that's when your BD comes in your
account managers come in but I think a
lot of businesses in my opinion quite
humble in my opinion but I feel
yeah they're all about the quick wins
now um
just just thought of this when you were
talking about that how long how long
would you give a how long would you give
a new market a chance you think Karen in
terms of like you've seen the things
that you've seen you've really given it
a real effort for X period of time but
then I don't know if there's a period
where you then have to make a decision
got another three six months ago and you
know what we've really given it a crack
maybe it wasn't quite what we expected
is that I don't know I don't know if
you've so I have experienced that as
well like I thought there's been one or
two markers where we're making money but
it's painful and it's good money but
it's painful it's not as consistent that
we would like so I would say depending
on experience level if I've got my best
person in a project that I feel I've
done the due diligence go in in money to
be made I think if it's my best person
I'll probably say two months three
months Max is enough and again I'll be
looking for green shoot are people
willing to talk to you or people
open to using agents because if in three
months you can't make it work it's
definitely not a skill because I've got
my best person on that my project is
probably is the market and there are
certain markets like that which are not
uh yeah they're not fertile so you
shouldn't be in those patches because
there's enough people or there's not
that much demand whatever the case may
be so I would say depending on skill
level but if you're a decent recruiter
360 two to three months should be enough
time for you to say okay this is not
working I need to get away because then
you're checking good money after bad
yeah no no that's really helpful so
let's talk about this this scaling
Journey then a lot of I'm sure you wear
like so many recruitment companies in
the UK a lot of them aren't 100 plus
people
um actually a very small percentage of
them are
so obviously I'm not sitting down with
the the founders of Thor but I think
you'll have a really interesting
perspective of you being a big part of
this journey and being on on the ride
what would you say let's start with the
challenges people want to know about
some of the the difficult periods and
some of the things that you really had
to work through like thinking about
scaling and growing successfully and
sustainably what would you say have been
some of the like biggest challenges or
hurdles that you've you guys have really
had to work through maybe approaching a
different way after approaching it a
certain way
um that are really that you had to work
through to get to where you are today
and continue to go in the right
direction were there any moments a lot
of people share of us that getting past
the sort of 20 foot haircut marks really
difficult their finances going back and
forward when you're yeah 50 to 100
people business then it's like I maybe
won't be able to have that family feel
that maybe we had before you know what I
mean there's all different challenges
along the journey I don't know if there
are any challenges that stick out in
your mind that you think wow we're back
here again let's try it this way you
know loads as you can imagine like that
that's yeah I can relate to all of the
things you've mentioned there I think
yeah getting to 30 and hovering around
that for a long period of time hiring
but then uh losing people as well we
generally don't lose people to
competition so we hire a lot of
Scandinavian people because we operate
in those countries so it's a case of
okay someone decides to go back home or
they want to go back to University or
they think the industry is not for them
to the usual challenges but yeah
hovering around the 30 then get into 50
okay sticking around 50 looking back
three months okay we're still 50. what's
happened yeah we lost three people there
so those are more uh I won't even call
them failures they're just learning
learning curves but we have to change
and adapt reality is covid was good it
was a good Catalyst for us we we landed
some really big hitters people who
probably felt what I felt at S3 that I'm
not being looked after so those were
good hires and we've built teams around
them so they've got already a well
no name they themselves a good known
well-known people in the industry so
when they come to us they bring a few
people with them so that helped the
growth aspect uh we upped our salaries
massively uh this year not mine but
everyone else's uh so yeah we've now the
grads that come in they come in at 25.
so that's again
you know being in line with the market
but also making sure we are appealing uh
we changed our commission scheme we've
introduced loads of benefits like loads
gym pension Insurance you name it so
that's a constant ongoing um you've got
to keep adapting uh move on with the
times but I would say the biggest
challenge in my opinion and it's
annoying because I sit somewhere in the
middle I've got the sales I've got the
growth I can see the people
is just making sure that people that are
coming into the business think and act
like us because eventually they will be
one of us or they will be owning a piece
of the pie or they will be running a
team a office somewhere as long as they
can think and act like us
um great so that's been the challenge of
getting the right people through yeah it
always tends to be that doesn't it which
is yeah so how is he curious like how
how do you think about
creating what you're saying they're
thinking like um think like an act like
us how do you think about cultivating
and influencing and protecting culture
especially being yeah over 100 person
organization you've got people in
different countries
um I don't know how do you think about
that how is there anything that you do
um uh internally that you think really
make sure that we have the best chance
of influencing the right culture and
protecting it protecting our standards I
don't know how personally do you think
about culture and and uh yeah
influencing it in the right way or
protecting it massively massively I
think when you talk about culture
um I I do a lot of interviews I speak to
a lot of recruiters Rec directs and all
that everyone's talking about culture
you know every recruitment company we've
got great culture we've got great ping
pong tables there's in our beers company
holidays so everyone's got that where
are you different what's your unique
point I think uh the biggest thing for
me what I'm trying to instill when I
speak to people is you've got the
you know you've got the S3s of this
world the Nigel Franks and all the big
players they're up there then you've got
the startups there's loads of them like
you said uh we're somewhere in the
middle so we've been through the hard
yards of a startup where yeah I was
getting the coffee we were having to do
everything ourselves ta marketing all
sorts and recruiting and then you've got
the big boys where everything's done the
top Management's in place the team
leaders the scene is everyone's play is
being looked after so if you're a
recruiter whether you've got a couple of
years under your belt or your fresh grad
I think being working for a company like
ours that is really good for you because
you're not having to do any of the hard
yards of a startup but you're also not
having to jump any red you know any
bureaucracy or any any Hoops there so
great great time to be here I think um
yeah the challenge with that is how do
you keep these people motivated and
Ticking along which is your question I
would say is constant uh reinforcing the
message the vision so you have a sales
meeting at the start of the month great
guys this is what we're doing this month
how often do you follow that up and how
often well let's say we've got a holiday
to Dubai as a Target how often are we
talking about it on the sales floor at
the coffee machine in the pub so people
are all you know on the same page then
the other piece would be
you know how how are you
engaging your stuff so I personally feel
I like to give the team I've got right
now
um I would like to give them more and
more responsibility because I know they
can do it but they also want to do it it
makes them feel
part of the business so for example if
I'm asking one of my seniors to run an
incentive as opposed to me running it
but you run it what do you think we need
accounting we need uh more interviews
that's what's lacking us well great
let's put a Target in place you've got
the budget but you're running it I trust
you
that conversation and there's you know
six seven eight team leaders in that
position they will then trickle that
down message they will trickle that
message down they'll pass on the
positivity they'll work with extra sort
of Consciousness because I've trusted
them and I think that's what's working
for us right now so that all sounds
really interesting I guess at this point
as we sort of come to the the end here
there's a couple of things I just wanted
to get your thoughts on one of the
things that you shared with me that you
feel like is one of the things you're
good at and I feel like you're just
talking about it there is is leadership
and sort of empowering people and I
think that is a really big part of
successfully growing your recruitment
business big yeah uh and I think that
can be uh really challenging for people
to get right I think ideally a lot of
recruitment owners that I speak to or
recruitment leaders they'd love to have
homegrown Talent they're getting to
leaders and these types of things but it
can be really difficult to
um yeah cultivate that and create that
so I guess the first thing that I just
I'm always curious to hear people's
thoughts online do you have any
leadership philosophies that you really
live by that you think enable you to
yeah get the most out of your team
Empower people uh don't know just any
sort of perspective on like what you
think good leadership looks like and the
things that you live by and really try
and cultivate and and help people with
uh when it comes to leadership and it's
in there to share
um loads like I said I just learn
I'm not naturally sort of a leader
leader but if I see you're doing
something good and I know I can benefit
from it I'll go and adapt and I'll apply
that but I think the basic ones
especially from a recruiting perspective
is lead by example you know so I
wouldn't be saying anything to my guys
something that I wouldn't do or they
can't do so I'll have that in mind so
leading leading with an example also you
know what I'm thinking what I'm wanting
from the team like communicating that
enough and and make it visible so that
we're all bought into the same vision so
having you having the
um yeah the vision that you have in mind
sharing that with your guys that really
helped leadership if I've got a Target
in my head that I need to make a million
pound profit this year let's say and I'm
not communicating that to my top leaders
when I'm driving them because they don't
know they're not bought into it so I'm
just constantly telling them like Aaron
this month this is the plan mate this
will be doing this is what it means for
you this one means for me this is yeah
we're going for it how do we get the
troops behind it so I think those two
things leading by an example having the
vision and I think you had Andrew on
your show still a toast or pick this up
from him the framework the management
framework okay how do we there's a
problem how do we solve it what options
do we've got so keeping keeping it
relevant keeping it fresh and revisiting
it that's for me a leadership style that
that works at least in my career has
worked for me I'm sure I can do lots
more
um
but yeah that seems to work and the
reality of the situation is when you're
working with like-minded people when
you're working with uh
the kind of people they've either
trained yourself or you've you've got
them into the business yourself that
does work because they're more or less
thinking like you as well yeah you've
what I've found really interesting in
this conversation is how often you've
used the word vision and I think when
when I think when I'm thinking of small
gram recruitment businesses I think
that's sometimes what can actually lack
like they're just thinking about what's
thoroughly in front of them and it's
hard not to think about those things but
I think when I was in a business
recruitment business of eight ten people
that's what I think actually really
lacked is like where are we all going
together why are we all in this together
and like how I can play a part of that
to get what I mean and I think sometimes
people think oh and then make sure we
have a really Crystal Clear Vision of
where we want to get to when we're a bit
bigger when we have more people do you
know what I mean and that's clearly like
you've talked about in the leadership
the growth of the business and I think
when you have really thought about where
you're taking your business or your team
you can then get people on that Journey
yeah but if you're just driving the
activities and there's do you know yeah
exactly so even when I'm running the you
know I'm meeting with my tier guys as
opposed to saying yeah we need to hire
these many people I'm more interested in
telling them why we're hiring them what
does it mean for you what does he mean
for the business and I think the the uh
that resonates more as opposed to just
saying guys 15 highs needed this quarter
off you go so it's like it's like
they're part of the journey and
incredible because you I think that
comes a lot from the concrete like
that's how they operate uh that's how we
were when we were a team of six you know
nine years ago we're now 130 we're still
working the same way so it works I
wouldn't change that so as we come to
the end here then I think I don't know
how you feel about things but depending
on how much you buy into negativity
online than these things as you said I
think one of the key learnings that you
shared of us in 2016 was the importance
on diversification clearly have that now
three different markets different
locations but as a business like what
what do you guys have top of mind going
into the next six 12 18 months I think a
lot of a lot of Finance people bring
them back to there would probably say
we're definitely going to a downturn for
how long we don't know there's
definitely challenges yeah a lot of
recruitment leaders I'm speaking to are
saying look we're still in a good
position but again want to make sure
that they're trying to make smart
decisions but what what are you having
top of mind going into the end of this
year next year sure where your guys and
girls might be in a different type of
market and be facing challenges where
they are going to have to use those
resilience muscles okay very good
question I think if I was to answer that
to the best of my ability I would say
we've had a really good 18 months offer
that includes you know the pandemic and
we've grown in Revenue we've grown in
headcount good like I said we've got
three brands currently I would say we're
good can we do better yes
uh what happens now and then is okay one
brand will do really good one might do
average and the third one might yeah up
and down or whatever so there's a lot of
dovetailing
um one month the us will have a PB month
and Europe will have a slow month why is
it worser so I think for me the next 18
months along with the other stakeholders
the managers the team leaders and
everyone's part of this it's not me or
or Nico Chris or the other man it's all
of us together we want to get that from
good to Great I.E all brands are
consistently delivering uh once we nail
that okay then then we're one step close
to this High performing culture that we
are trying to achieve uh hopefully we
achieve that in the next 15 to 18 months
we've got some real real uh strong uh
projects internally like good projects
internally that will help us to achieve
that
um so that'd be my next 18 months to get
from good to great I know it might sound
cheesy but we've got a good business can
we get more yes I think we can scale up
a bit more we can sharpen up a little
bit more in terms of how to maximize the
existing uh markets we work in how can
we maximize the opportunities in those
markets because I feel like at times I
feel like we're scratching the surface
there's so much more we can achieve for
me so those are the next 18 months and I
feel okay if we can nail that then the
following 18 months
again we would just want to carry on
growing in revenue and head count we
have got a Target in place what we want
to be by the summer of next year and the
summer after and so on so those will be
just Milestones that are just in the
background you do a business plan every
year regigig at the year after see where
you were short so I think best way to
summarize or answer your question would
be we're good today what would be great
that's the 18 month plan for us so let's
end it on this then there'll be a lot of
people listening that haven't had that
have only experienced Good Times
loads of jobs candidates that are
challenged but they're doing deals
they're having PBS you've been through a
number of different markets and
challenges
um but what what would your advice be
for people listening to this recruiters
that yeah maybe over the next 12 months
they are going to experience more
knockbacks and rejections and challenges
that maybe they've
um ever experienced before I don't know
yeah if there's anything that you uh
would leave people with that could maybe
uh help them be best prepared for
potentially experiencing more challenges
than they've ever experienced I think
your ability to self-reflect so like if
you're doing the same you're canvassing
the same people
um day in day out and not getting the
results okay so first of all question
who you're conversing while you're
comforting while you're coming why are
you pitching them and then if we can
learn from your mistakes and just go
into next day with the mentality that I
want to improve that'd be the first more
or less like an attitude self-aware
mindset okay am I doing the right thing
am I doing the right activity at the
right time if not can I do that but I
would also say like if you could have a
think about a complimentary Market start
preparing in advance okay if you like
you said there's a recession coming
um okay what markets in your opinion
would not be impacted by this for
instance during covid the sales of uh
health equipment you know gym your your
cycling things
sorry yeah that went through the roof
laptops sales were Sky High everyone
wanted laptops to work from home so if
you've got that commercial awareness
which was you know I mentioned when you
said what makes a good recruiter I think
that that will allow you to okay this
Market is going through a tough time
I'll cash in while I can but I need to
start thinking about what else is going
to be hot what's coming in the best way
to do if you're good enough you should
be asking your clients you should be
asking your candidates who you know
let's be honest I'm I've been privileged
to work with some senior level people
they obviously know a lot more about the
industry than I do I'm just a young grad
calling them from a very fancy office in
in Corn Hill for S3 hey do you want a
new job but they are the experts right
so I would be asking those guys whoever
whichever Market you work in to learn
about what's the next evolving
technology that you need to be getting
onto lover Karen thank you so much
thank you so much for listening to the
episode I hope you enjoyed it and got
value from the conversation if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode